la caravana de miles de emigrantes se
encuentra en este momento fragmentada en
diferentes puntos de huixtla al sur de
méxico nos encontramos en uno de ellos
un polideportivo donde los migrantes
pernoctan a la espera de resolver su
estatus migratorio pero en huixtla a
diferencia de tapachula los migrantes y
han encontrado mayor recepción y
diligencia de parte de las oficinas de
aduana de entregarles los formatos
múltiples de migración que los blindan
por 30 días de ser capturados y
deportados a sus países de origen
obtenido este visado una gran parte de
los migrantes con los que hemos
conversado continuará su camino a pie
pero muchos otros saldrán en buses desde
aquí de huixtla hasta ciudad de mexico
posteriormente a la frontera sur de los
eeuu en específico al borde limítrofe
con texas donde les han dicho que el
caudal del río bravo es bajo esta llega
hasta las rodillas y es mucho más fácil
para ellos cruzar los de una manera
ilegal